welcome to the recruitment rollercoaster
podcast that my name is Hisham azuz and
today I'm joined by James Weiser who is
the director of raw recruitment hi
thanks for having me thanks for joining
me my pleasure
actually I've been really looking
forward to this so if I you are like a I
don't know recruitments Liberty now and
when I saw you I was almost I've seen
LinkedIn quite a few now you're in the
flesh so yeah definitely mate but what I
was excited because if I think they
haven't had Locker
I haven't had someone that I mean you've
done rhetoric for how long it would be
16 years next year yeah exactly so I
mean that's bad mental yeah I'm not
having I haven't had someone sort of
from a sort of rhetoric perspective for
a while now I just think it's such a you
have so you're in such a unique position
to like just actually be honest around
what you're saying what you're not
saying do you know I mean and I think
that's so valuable for and people
listening so um before we sort of
uncover this 16 years of ret reck life
how did you get into the world of
recruitment mate well unlike most people
who fell into it I actually wanted to go
into it from about the age of 18 one of
my parents friends they had a daughter
who was what about 22 23 working leads
okay and she was in 80 grand a year
really and I was like okay I'm not an
academic I'm sitting it could be a
doctor or a vet or a lawyer
but I wouldn't want anything 80 grand a
year so ever since I kind of found out
about that which wants to be a recruiter
which is why I told my parents wasn't
too fast and getting good results
because I'm being a recruiter as long as
you could speak and have a bit of banter
someone and that you know hard-working
you were going to be successful all
right yeah so where did you grow up grow
up in the Cotswolds you know when to
boarding school in Birmingham at the
boarding school yeah I did oh wow
how's that do you know what first she
was pretty horrific
yeah that's pretty hard being you guys
how old are you 11
yeah I always think when I do not mean
do you know I really want to go to my
parents had a really messy divorce
and yeah first you would say it was hard
I came from a very rural you know local
school and I joined enough I was had
masses of ginger hair and a rotund
stomach and so I was called fat orange
for the first year and add in particular
like standard prepared me for a sales
floor of panthous environment but um I
didn't know there me it's more like
African yes although when you what's
that mean you know you've got those
little what they call it like Modi's or
where they're called
he's definitely ginger yeah I think
that's quite a realistic emoji my son
points to it says daddy so yeah but you
know what as soon as I kind of got to
level where I start playing sport
basically in you know he started selling
it sport I just really loved boarding
school in it yeah it gave me a rubbing
with him I was yeah
I can't became to be the best road
player but yeah I was alright fair
enough ain't no just interested that cuz
like I don't know like how many mates
it's hard in that honey makes you have
when you get plunked in Birmingham and
you go school ya know everyone was in
the same situation and I just think you
know I just taught me such an amazing
you know skill set away from academia it
was more about how you handled yourself
I think borders you're on your own at
that ia just ISA yeah it's tough I lived
at home until I was 20 well until last
year Wow alight and then do my only
other experiences that was when I worked
abroad for two summers we'll call it me
or cup it as Mike leave like that was
and that was the only other time that I
was sort of away from parents and at
home so that must definitely have taught
you some stuff yeah I think resilience
is a really big factor for me um how I
can have endless drop outs and yeah of
course it annoys me and like anyone but
it's just that abilities kind of push it
to one side and just crack on with
what's in front of me and I think that's
kind of preparing really well for a
career and recruitment because it
doesn't matter how good you are or you
know how long you've been doing you're
always gonna get those knock back so
yeah yeah I love boarding school it gave
me a really good start in life and I'm
very fortunate enough to come so you
found out that you could have quite a
bit of money recruitment yeah
was the approach to get into recruitment
and how I tell me that stuff so one of
my friends his brother's best friend was
you know recent recruiter and had
recently set up a wreck to wreck and
mentioned he was looking he said that I
was interested so the chap gave me a
call when I was at uni one day wasn't
kind of expecting it phone rang my bed
aren't at Hulu and he said are you you
know you want to get into recruitment
and I had a kind of Timoney if he's like
right you've got the job I was cool
fantastic so that was about it really
and he was at uni at this point I was at
uni yeah what was you doing not much
really studying I was studying Business
Studies oh yeah when at school I applied
to get Cardiff and the main reason
behind that was the Rugby World Cup 99
Rugby World Cup was happening that year
okay and I put you at the time it's
Cardiff met now for you at the time as
done in a second
ice predicted the grace to get in but I
was more fussed about playing rugby and
showing parents around the school so I
came out with shocking a-levels which
meant Ont basically Cardiff Poly and you
know whereas I'm their kind of you know
hammering graduates nowadays like why
they had a privileged upbringing did
really badly in their a-levels
I was yeah sadly one of those people say
it was always you know I wanted to gun
sales I was always quite good at
building rapport people I kind of
thought yeah that's definitely saying
for me repair Union no I didn't drop out
I didn't know I failed my first year oh
wow
which was very horrific I actually kind
of that time was working in a pub for
some holidays when I got the grades and
I call my dad and say look you know
basically I failed I've screwed up and I
got offered a managerial position in the
pub I was working in and the position
paid 12 grand a year and I I was working
the shift that night after getting
offered and I kind of went out to garden
to my dad and basically called him in
tears and said look dad that's not for
me I just don't want to do it if I
promise to commit you know coming back
to uni and luckily my dad said yes and
then went back to uni I was slightly
hard-working still came over to - but
yeah you news great fun night
I don't think University is all about
what you come out for
totally great it's more about you know
just how much you learn how much you put
myself out there these societies are
joined and that's kind of interestingly
what I look for in a candidate
especially at the junior ends he's
always kind of extracurricular things
because I probably can't relate to the
academia side so um ya know it's really
interesting you say that and just just
on that point so I I didn't go to
university had no idea what I wanted to
do so I was like know what I'm not gonna
go because if I don't know what to do
my brother younger brother on the other
hand he's in he went to UCL he's in
those like placement um like he's like
full-on I could like that academia world
like I just mentor like totally
different to what I'm about but I
couldn't agree more the conversations
and and friends that I've had that gone
into university it's all the or
conversation always have is more about
the people they met the relationships
that I've made the like you just said
they're extra things at the ended up
getting involved in that they really
enjoyed and actually more of the
experience of them finding out more
about themselves and being away from
their sort of comfortable environment at
home and stuff that tends to be the
conversation rather than I've got a 2-1
do you know I mean so I totally get that
yeah definitely are they that has
changed a lot so when our guys rule
interview graduates one of the first
things we kind of focus on is you know
the academia side and if it kind of gets
a tutti I mean give you a fish I've
pasted three people a thirds my place
over a thousand people in the
recruitment industry so like place over
a thousand people in the air even I've
got a little black book every single
person I've ever place really yeah
that's mental yeah and only three have
ever got thirds they've had amazing
stories and they've had a cracking
personalities but if it wasn't for that
you know they wouldn't got a job so
today people play such an emphasis on
doing well at university I think that's
you know a lot of people say look if you
didn't you know I was described would
have been described at lady university
know rightfully so but when I first
started in wreck to wreck you could have
a tutu from our views university play
you know football for a stunningly team
and if you could speak you got a job in
recruitment and then in 2008 when the
credit crunch happened there was a big
adjustment in you know what was the
typical hiring strategy of companies and
said hey you know business you know law
wasn't hiring banking wasn't hiring and
so you had these incredibly talented
highly academic students graduating
couldn't go into their first choice kind
of industries and so they were falling
into recruitment Wow and ever since then
I think there's been a know if I'm
honest an unrealistic expectation of you
know what the market can deliver on mass
that's really interested in so okay then
so just just to help frame helps
everyone understands what to marette for
sixteen years but come on sixteen years
of C and then else he started rule how
long did you start rule so rules been
going coming up to almost five years so
yeah prior to that I had eleven years
experience working for the rights
records w6 yeah cool so and then rule
what do you do now so is it grads and
experience higher so operon and butters
and agencies very much kind the grad
higher you know if something came to us
with a mandate for you know trying for
the graduate or ten graduate so it'd be
really comfortably can do that however
me personally kind of place people more
like director managing director level
yes we kind of cover the whole spectrum
but yeah and that's kind of across UK
and overseas but the majority of our
business is kind of conducted in London
okay and it's predominately grads into
recruitment businesses yeah that is
changing there's a lot of second job as
in there yeah more kind of like some or
someone who's got into a cream and year
experience maybe a bit less or yeah I
mean candidates King in this market so
if we have a candidate with three years
experience we could place we've got can
date with five years experience can
place them so it's really what comes
through a door to an extent yeah that's
fair enough okay cool and then and then
prior to that sw6
yeah the same sort of thing yeah I get
again there was one person doing you
know experienced guys the rest of it was
very much you know grad entry-level I
mean I worked there for five years
obviously they're a competitor of mine
now and as far as I'm aware they still
do that when I thought that he was doing
that it was sort of similar stuff that
when you was there yes to be six up it
was very much a grad grad model yeah so
this is your bread and butter than
really been than grad piece yeah yeah
definitely
really yeah and then more recently
you've been personally yeah I do a lot
more experience which I really enjoy and
I think just because you haven't
recruit me for a long time it's just
it's nice to have a slight change and I
just think having you know slightly more
gravitas in the market largely because
of you know being a bit older than
unfortunately next year you just
naturally I did you know it's easy to
deal with more senior candidates yeah
and so many people I've placed you know
will come back to me or therefore it's
just you know tapping two slightly
different kind of pool okay cool so
first thing that I'd love to get your
thoughts on let's just focus on the sort
of more recent things and what you mean
what's being gone on in your world
because it just made sense to do that so
I guess what I'd love to know is like so
how how do you sell recruitment to grads
do you know what when I first started
saying recruitment of graduates like you
could grand new first-year you know that
is not the case certainly not nowadays
and then one person who's done that and
you know no one else and nowadays it's
kind of I still recruitment very
differently how he's probably fifteen
sixteen years ago and I tell it's a
career nowadays really so when I first
start out recruitment is kind of
industry work in for you know two three
years you'd work bloody hard you don't a
bit of money you know you buy a house
and you know before you're 30 to
probably move on
where's recruitment nowadays you know it
gives a genuine opportunity to build a
crit but in terms of ceilings graduates
are just the biggest thing I love about
recruitment is you know glad you could
go into law at gun team banking and
dentistry could be a nurse but the one
thing recruitment offers over any of
those is a truly meritocratic industry
where if you do this you'll be promoted
to that if you build this you earn that
and I just love the black and white yeah
so my wife used to work in you know she
was really senior board director of a
branding communication business and you
know at the end of the year her bonus
was very much kind of fight yeah I think
she's worth that it wasn't tangible like
in recruitment and I think it's the
beautiful thing about recruitment cos
you know you win do you like that you
have an earnest and someone's been
luckier but the results don't lie ya
know I [ __ ] angry mom I think as soon
as I got my first flavor of sales I
there's no way that I could sit next to
James he does the same job as me
and does it half-assed and gets paid the
same I couldn't think of anything worse
you say that a funny enough we talked
about this in the office today and there
are a number of recruitment agencies in
the market that do exactly that so they
went at Inc where they operate a team
commission basis so there are business
out there where you have five people a
team for example the team builds X they
were paid the team to him percent and
then the team spit that pot and it
doesn't matter what I started to buy in
yeah sure i Speights someone I'm not
going to say the company in my rib its
average father guys a few affairs I
spoke to a guy who actually told me this
the other day and I was just like no way
they do but they don't know there's an
alternate relations thing and we talked
about so I give meetings and people say
well what do you put in for that company
I'm like it's more difficult you think
they've almost been brainwashed because
what if I've worked you know 10 more
hours in you in a week and I've built
twice as much why should I get paid the
same oh yeah when you approach people
from these businesses they kind of think
yeah what you're selling you know you're
selling isn't true and yeah I just don't
understand it I mean there are
businesses out there that you know
really do Roadstar from really well
nowadays because it's such a competitive
market but yeah to work for a firm ah
yeah I think it's looking at mission
yeah dreadful no way I can do it team
commission yeah ten percent I couldn't
believe it actually can't believe when I
heard that I was like there's no way I
there's no way I could also the bigger
organizations that I kind of won't
mention you know it's not team
commission but you know they tend to pay
the graduates in terms of people you
know decent level basic salary is far
more than you know what a lot of the
majority of business I work with but
would pay but they pay discretionary
bonuses so again it's you know there are
lots of companies in criminal do that I
just posed more the business I work with
that's you know tend to reward maura
meritocratic you know way I couldn't
agree more that that's what I loved
about working in recruitment but
particularly in sales I was like okay so
I'm in complete control of what I put in
is what I get back sort of thing and I
couldn't agree more I think that's great
so you more go down that route that what
you put in what you get out and it is a
career yeah definitely do you how
how do you think recruitments a career
now honey how do you like how because we
spoke about this a lot at their sort of
live event how sort of recruitment is
actually really now becoming a
profession and these types of things
obviously it's a process and stuff but
would you agree with that yeah
definitely look I know you shouldn't
talk about age but I'm going to and it's
to illustrate an example so ten years
ago if you were thirty you were
considered quite an old hat you'd pretty
be a direct recruitment man yeah um
nowadays so for example I was working
with candidate the other day who's got
17 years experience in b2b sales for a
really you know for a decent car
manufacturer and he has joined a fin
tech recruiting business in London and
he's 40 years old no Crimmins be had the
skill set and there's no way that would
have happened kind of ten years ago his
driver then why did that happen he just
wanted to earn more money he kind of
capped out and it was kind of like well
I kind of anymore on this I know
recruitment I'm gonna take a massive
step back but in three four years time I
can exceed the earnings I'm earning
which is good but I mean I suppose I'll
use that point team I say demonstrate
that recruitment has got you know shelf
life nowadays you're getting much older
minute I said I'm 40 next year and I
don't feel anywhere near the end of my
recruitment career where's it hatched
eggs get up you think oh my god I'm like
40 next day there's no way I could be
improvement and I think much hair did
you have when you started no you're
totally right so that would that would
just never would happened that often
that's amazing yeah definitely and I
just think that recruiting businesses on
the whole have just kind of grown up
it's not you know yeah of course there
are those really you know kind of old
schoolboy
cowboy clubs where you know the bash
graduates for three four years you know
take a pound of flesh spit them out and
then they get the next batch whereas
there are so many businesses now that
are doing things a much more consorted
way it allows much more I suppose
sophisticated
more mature individuals to kind of like
you know kick on their career so from
your perspective then how how do you
think we can as you know recruiters
don't have the best reputation rector X
even more worse worse than that from
what I understand being in this sort of
world of recruitment and moving to
London and stuff but on that no it's
something to be spoke about the event
and I'd love to get your perspective on
because it's be something that you're
selling on a daily basis like how do you
think we can do more to to actually
showcase and communicate recruitment as
a great career choice we know there's
always gonna be recruiters who are gonna
be bashed because there's always going
to be a client who gets frustrated with
the service you deliver you might not
get candidate shows up you know there's
so many you know factors out of your
control as a recruiter yeah that can
have a read decremental and the most
annoying thing is it often happens like
buses so if you get canned it drops out
from a client meeting you know they've
done probably two more you know can't
it's drop out from that client that week
and it makes you that really [ __ ] as an
agency but sometimes it's just down to
you know pure and luck in terms of you
know creating a more consult environment
it's just giving people the opportunity
to you know do a good job I think
recruiters nowadays are much more
understanding of their markets they you
know I mean I I know technical
recruiters for example can learn how to
code you know that never would have
happened like 10-15 years ago and
recruiters are properly understanding
the market space and I truly believe
that you know you can add value but you
know it's 40,000 recruitment firms in UK
yes there's a lot of [ __ ] out there but
equally there's some really good
businesses out there who offer like a
really high you know they offer really
high standard solution yeah and
obviously to be fair I don't I don't
so obviously a lot of people would say
like us in LinkedIn like people just
bashing recruiters and stuff but I
shouldn't i actually never see that but
I think that's because I'm recruited
it's connects to like loads of
recruiters and stuff but I think it's
totally right I think for me it's things
like this and everything else all the
good stuff there's so much great stuff
that can be spoken about the recruiting
agencies are doing they just need that
people needs to be more loud about do
you not I mean you know in any industry
you're gonna get you know you get people
kind of let them the sex it down but
equally gonna get people who kind of
like you know stand up be counted and
I'd do a really good job
and I think just as human beings you
kind of focus on the negativity thing
about you know it's often you want
tripAdvisor's looking at the hotel and
you get five people say it's absolutely
[ __ ] and you know I would never go to a
hotel and write about how amazing it is
but if you had a really bad experience
you might write about it and I think
it's that and I'm often told that a lot
something that happened in real criminal
our point than that remember that
what's that there's like a current
member what they were called but someone
tries to make a TripAdvisor for
recruitment agencies they did remember
that yeah I do I'm pretty sure it's a
lot flopped I don't know and I won't say
and but do you remember seeing that yeah
I do yeah a fairly young guy who yeah
yeah obviously yeah that's just change
like million times I don't think you
really need an environment because like
having those kind of portals it's only
gonna encourage negative publicity the
forty percent of our revenue rule comes
from referrals really yeah
and that's so common in recruitment
businesses it is we do it well and I
think if you relook after graduate or
anyone any recruiter or you know any
candidate and you do a really good job
and you literally wrap them up in you
know cotton mall when you give them a
really good experience they're gonna
tell their friends and their friends and
everything they're gonna think about you
I think so many people are so
short-sighted about you know spot based
got a place there's got to do that
because that but if you think about the
bigger picture and actually offering a
really good service but then you will
get repeat business and you know I think
so many recruiters are kind of like you
know have that kind of outlook nowadays
while we're talking about this I'd love
to get your opinion on just a sort of
time with this and talking about so
recruitment is a career and how it's
been perceived and stuff like this
how how another sort of topic that a lot
of people was talking about is to like
talking about being a recruiting who's
future-proof and what the future looks
like and these types of things like
obviously you speak to businesses all
day repair businesses like how how do
see recruitment businesses thinking
about the future and ensuring that their
future proof and what's your thoughts on
that
I think it's really difficult it's kind
of future proof yourself and that there
will be businesses out there who you
know her far more successful you know we
are and you know they will kind of talk
about their strategies about doing that
but on the whole it's really difficult
to do it because I think if you and
especially have a difficult political
and economical landscape at the moment
it's very difficult you know you look at
things like the oil and gas market the
oil and gas market in 2000 and what 9 10
was ab c-- beaming you know price of all
was around $140 a barrel it dropped to
20 you know $20 a barrel and sending oil
and gas recruitment which kind of you
know arguably save the rabbit market you
know for me back in 2010 when everyone
else was screwed went under so what did
you learn through that period then
because a lot of people listening
wouldn't have been through that do you
know I'm sorry talking how do you make
sure that you know I mean yeah I mean I
think you've got a look it's a rediff
achill strategy because a lot of
recruitment consultants talk about
working a inch-wide mile deep yeah
market and therefore you come a real
expert your market your market gets hit
mmm it means you're screwed but then
again I speak to a lot of decent
recruiters and they have the competence
their ability where by the sector they
work in is literally so you can be
learnt in three six months but their
ability to recruit is you know they can
take with them from market to market
okay nice interest in so I'd love to get
your opinion on this what's your view on
working for a bigger agency compared to
a smaller agency
oh okay difficult because I work with
both I mean we do work with smaller
agencies in the whole and like any
recruit it's more favorable with the
term isabela they move quicker less
process can go directly to you you know
it says you makers but for someone
listening it depends what stage you're
at in your career it depends what
individual because I think both
opportunities lend themself to you know
potentially successful careers and
there's not anything saying you can't
move between one the other I did
people go from small business to big
businesses but you see a lot of people
go from big businesses small businesses
so I think the cons for well let's start
the pros I think the pros for big
businesses are they give you a brand
name they give you really structured
training they can give you a ready built
kind of social life it's kind of on a
platform it's not as difficult
especially the market nowadays is so tax
rated telling a kind of grad who's you
know three weeks out of university going
BD against a guy who's been doing it you
know or girl who's been doing it you
know five six seven eight years you're
gonna stand very little chance where's
the big business I think a branding
carries a lot of weight you know the
cons are potentially a lot slower to
progress because they've already got a
brand name maybe white tides are gonna
get that and they team well yes well you
know simply simply lower-level
Commission um in terms of you know a
working for smaller agency yeah you
might not get the same training you're
probably gonna get direct training from
something's actually been there and done
it and you know is a top of the game and
I personally think that isn't invaluable
there's also opportunity so you know a
small business will look to promote
people rather than reasons not to
promote people they tend to have much
you know they tend to have less overhead
so not a nice offices therefore they can
form more Commission I mean me
personally I would always prefer to work
for a smaller agency because I think it
presents more opportunity but my reasons
for wanting to recruitment perhaps very
different than elses so no yeah I'll
just interested to get your point on
that I mean makes complete sense
everyone's individual depends on what
their objectives are the type of person
they are but for me yeah I I agree I'd I
would always so I worked for like a big
insurance company and worked for a small
insurance broker and then went into a
person recruitment agency and I'd always
personally pick that just because as you
said having direct access to the owner
of the business that was just really
invaluable to me yeah but I mean just
just on that note I think it makes a
massive difference about who the owner
that business is totally so if I'm
selling against a small business I will
look at what the cash flow is on company
income B's house also then look at the
pedigree of the person running that
business if that guy is a lady again
it's been you know running a recruiting
business for you know ten years and the
three people big I would kind of
question the pedigree of that business
well if there's someone who's build
maximum of 150 grand a year have they
got the ability to trains you to be a
three 400 Billa no whereas if you look
at some people who's done startup
businesses they've been five six seven
okay billa's or they've been CEOs of big
businesses before and they know how to
do it and I think joining someone a
journey you need to be really careful
back joining the right people because
there are loads of small businesses that
aren't going anywhere and probably won't
go anywhere really good point on that
point please do be honest and though you
will be but if I'm a recruit right now
listening and I am coming to a bit of a
crossroads obviously besides come and
speak to rule but nonetheless I'd really
appreciate your advice on this for
people like if I've got years experience
eighteen months experience as you said
if you have someone comes you guys
you're very confident you'll place them
and no doubt if I've got that top of
experience on again absolutely smashed
by rhetorics
hitting hit with LinkedIn messages all
day phoned at my desk sometimes maybe
but like old school yeah old school but
like if I if I'm considering a move
right now I think you're just talking
about they're like really think about
obviously who you are and what you want
and the type of people you can learn
from but what what should I really be
looking out for like what are the RET
like what the red flags when I'm
considered in a moved you know I mean
like what are the things that I need to
be thinking about so I'd always
encourage them it's having to cry in the
marketplace it's amazing how many people
you see have four years tenure and one
recruiting business yeah they leave and
then they've left their necks cream
pisses in for five months and it's
because they don't invest in the process
so then they're kind of scare paps going
to be caught haven't got time to
interview so it's kind of like don't see
a couple of companies yeah great I'll
accept the first thing that's offered
and perhaps you know put less effort in
them when they were kind of graduating
that's the first good point then like if
you are gonna look around yeah actually
really invest in the process and make
sure you actually do look around I think
the biggest thing that any candidate
based is their decision on is around
coming culture I think when you pick a
business that you're gonna be happy in
you're pretty gonna stay there and
company cultures can vary massively so
just given idea rule we place for one
hundred and sixteen different Cretan
businesses last year oh well which is
not so that expands
contingent an exact search predominately
in London
if you ever cease few in the regions but
predominate in London and those hundred
sixteen businesses you know very
massively in terms of how much paid
spend base what the trains light what
the cultures like what offices like what
you get to where can you bring your dog
you know it's just a million factors I
just bring someone like myself who's
been to meet all these companies we
really kind of profile we get to find
out I think in mainstream recruitment
you look at something CV you magic with
job spec and you say wow that person's
coated five years in Python they're
perfect for that position whereas for me
it's much more about profiling someone's
personality and magic in the company
culture and if we do that it works so
we're really finding out about the
person and I think that's what we do
really effectively is a right to wreck
how but how if I'm is so obviously
without besides I've seen you telling me
what that cultures like let's say you're
not involved yeah yeah how could I what
what would your advice be to try and
soak up as much that culture as possible
no interview process because that's such
about it's that is that basically it's
like if you are thinking about leaving
then one as you said really invest in
the process and if you're doing it
behind closed doors or whatever and you
might be more prone to just making a
quick decision which then means you
might leave in four months because you
didn't invest in the process get that
great advice but and then clearly it's
gonna come down to the people the
culture as you said it's really
important but how can i as someone
that's considering a move I mean how
could what what's the best way for me to
really try and get a grasp of that
before I decide to join them do you know
I mean I think you need to kind of think
about what you'd like about what you're
doing what you don't like where you're
struggling you know where you're kind of
thriving and then kind of think about
what you you know main purposes are so I
think a lot of creatures are bad at
listening to their own advice and if
there is an itch scratch it and if there
is that edge think about exactly what
you want you know where do you want to
be based I I mean for example people
have a bit of a commute that can put
people off you know that is a big issue
for you you think about moving to an
agency it's like closer yeah if you want
an agency of less KPIs join a smaller
organization if you want a thumping big
base and that's really important to you
over like a decent commission structure
there maybe join a bigger business if
you want settings more corporate again
so there's so many different factors
it's kind of hard to give but map again
good advice make the time to actually
understand we want more of one less of
invest and recruiters do you know what
um I think I'm a cream consultancy you
kind of get often and this is obviously
generalizing we get the top twenty
percent of people on a business who
really well they're really happy they've
got no desire to move until you know one
day an opportunity might come up or you
know perhaps moving out with London
because of you know relocation sense you
might come up but you know let's say
they're happy you then kind of get the
next you know batch of people who you
know bill well and relatively happy and
most of the time you know they're pretty
content and their job and then you get
like the bottom twenty percent of people
who are tickly good and don't enjoy the
job at all and it's about which I
suppose set of people you're looking to
target yeah excuse me but with the
medium kind of like people I suppose you
need to think about it's really
difficult to articulate I suppose okay
that's alright I suppose there's so many
questions that go around my head so when
I interview Candida it's not a case of
right his full questions fill this out
and give me your answer I have a
question after question after question
after question after question what are
they billing were they doing what market
where they want to be going what you
want to be doing and it's kind of
building up a real almost my map yeah in
my head of you know where these people
should perhaps should be you know
focusing their attentions try to get
that on this on this topic of moving
looking are agencies what I should be
thinking about international recruitment
moving abroad that's something that the
recruitment skillset can definitely
neighbor you today how much of that do
you do yeah I mean we place people who
you know all over the world so what is
the actual landscape of taking more
recruitment skillset right now I'm
moving to Australia or the USA what does
actually a lot right now I think if
you're a good recruiter and you got a
criminal record you got perhaps a degree
in some cases you know it's it's fairly
easy moment he's getting is constantly
changing around how many people are
hiring so I'm sure you're aware that in
Australia they've made a little more
difficult you know you have to earn you
know the employees have to pay their
staff certain amount of money and in
order to kind of justify that amount
you've pretty good have like 2/3 it's
experience yeah
in the states you know a lot of
businesses from the UK have moved up the
stakes and they've wreaths rived and
they're making a huge amount of money
out there but I've been told by a number
of clients in the last couple of months
is becoming increasingly more difficult
to get out there really but they're
approved and I just think that's kind of
under you know Trump it's becoming more
difficult you know there are other
markets really picking up so Amsterdam's
becoming a real hub for people to move
to Berlin Frankfurt Hamburg and I think
recruitment companies are looking to
come really global and given the fact
that you know the majority of you know
really high profile recruiting
businesses are established in London you
know they're looking to kind of create a
global footprint mmm but also you know
safeguard themselves against any kind of
downturn or you know what breaks it or
you know anything
so anyone listening they're a hundred
percent there's an opportunity to take
there I think that's such a great thing
as well isn't it like how not how easily
but like there's such an opportunity to
take your skill set abroad isn't like
that's completely real 100 percent but
what's really weird is okay so I you've
got wife kids they're at school I've got
a house got a mortgage got a business
it's very difficult for me to kind of
you know up sticks and move although I'd
love to live in stays it'd be awesome if
I was mid-20s with no dependents and I
thought you know what it's gonna have
like two three years of you know fun
maybe a bit more i 100% be out there I
mean the amount of money the US
counterpart a billing against you know
the UK recruiters is vast is that
although is that is that real no I think
as a wreck to wreck or you know like any
recurrent business I'm fed the detail
that I want to be that I need to be sold
basically so I sell it and they you know
the right way but yeah I I think
recruitment over there like fees are
often 25-30 percent yeah because there's
strength of the dollar over the pound as
well you know
you're running far more it just in you
know it's what 300 million people live
in the state yeah and there's it's also
a few recruitment agent recitation as
well it's a lot totally different than a
lot of recruiters perceived wait yeah
you know if you if you pick up the phone
to a company the states they want to
speak to you rather than you know
somebody in the UK there's often
barriers okay so big pillars how many
are there modern today's market like you
know I mean how much is that chance you
know what it has changed a lot it there
without question million pound bill is
in the marketplace and yeah yeah and we
work with a number of chrimbus nurses
who have you know a number of those
people in there however there aren't
nearly as many as used to be I think
kind of going back to the you know late
90s early noughties there were
recruiters you know who basically lived
like stockbrokers they earn a lot of
money but they've already big you know
it just wasn't saturated me just give
you an idea when I start to write direct
let's put about five rector exits put
about five thousand five in out loads
man yeah loads so it's it's much more
difficult now but arguably a lot of
chrimbus is I mean saying look although
it'd be lovely to have a million pound
Bella it's not great if they walk out
the door because what's left behind them
it's not loads people billing a hundred
grand you know you much rather have a
strategy where you have you know
everyone billing between 150 and 250
grand yeah so what is because again I
think this is again this is the sort of
stuff that I wanted to have access to
when I was in recruitment like what what
would you say is locker in terms of
Billings wise like what is like a real
good solid achievable amount that people
can it's like so right now I might be
listening the top billing might be
billing 180 K do not I mean however
there's gonna be a lot of other people
that are billing more than that but you
obviously so I had a few times on on
this podcast where a real common topic
that people ask me about is like Hisham
I'm billing 150k and I'm really
struggling to break the 200k mark I love
leads love we just talk to people about
how they've done that I'm billing 250 K
on and Britain 300 K market cetera et
cetera and quite a few times and I've
had
people on here and they went from one
agency to another agency and the first
agency the top bit it was like 200k web
and then they went so not really someone
been in foreign ok and all of a sudden
that becomes realistic and that's that's
actually I can actually do that if
someone in this room doing that do you
know I mean so that was like a I don't
know a big if
what was your sort of thoughts on like
what is like a real good achievable
amount that's like I mean I think if I
interview anyone they're billing naught
a 200 grand that I consider them to be a
pretty good recruiter okay in today's
market you know I think you're pretty
exceptional be building anything of like
four or five hundred bands I think you
know a really decent recruiter therefore
and you know anyone who's billing say
seven figures is just a bit of a freak
if I'm honest I think there's an element
of luck to that I think you know right
time right place right client called in
but also you occasionally get these
individuals who you know make everyone
else you know who think their money
hungry and think the hard-working you
know they're just they're just different
animals yeah by yeah I think about 200
grand but obviously depends how long
you've been in the business but this
interesting point so I interview the
candidate of a day and he considers his
hundred eighty five grands be amazing
because the top burner in his business
bills 190 exactly I'm like look I don't
mean to be disrespectful but you've got
several years tenure that is not great
yeah you know you could each be working
the business that allows you to bill
much more how I'm like well you work in
a business that hires loads of graduates
and therefore no one can see how to get
to the next level
yeah but equally the feel of are you're
working out as well might Hindu so you
know he was working on an average of
about four grand the fee and you know
you have to do about five and a half K
average fee and that yeah you're totally
right there is that so many people say
to me like why do you do rectum out you
know the average fee is like four or
five grand I'm like you know why do say
it's 20 grand average fee I'm like okay
yeah it's a fair point but that can it's
worth 20 grand over my you know five
grand is probably four times as likely
yeah it's difficult to find or convince
or find the right role for I mean a tuna
grand biller in one market no large is
turned a grand bit in another market and
I kind of say that with a bit of
hesitancy because there are markets out
there that I'd
any work with so rule work with
specialist markets that's like finance
banking technology / digital life
sciences legal market but they're about
why I just think that's what I've always
done I think it's more specialist in the
market it's probably easy to sell to
high-level candidates
okay but if you take someone from like
education recruitment background or a
service care or a health I mean I
suppose we can the update and their
Billings well astronomical what you
build they shouldn't my 650 grand
placing nurses yeah I've heard this yeah
fifty grand a year doing but anyone who
owns a kind of businesses they must be
laughing because they pay two
consultants burger or money but funny
enough a lot of our clients in the kind
of like more specialist recruitment I
don't want to see these cameras because
they've got no ability to well actually
understand well it's just didn't bring
them to a framework so it's basically a
glorified delivery role so it's just
matter you know matching candidate to
role and yes Mormon I'm illustrating for
all the phone there's no skill around
the business of element which you know
is increasingly becoming more difficult
and therefore there's more emphasis put
on you know B D than probably ever
before when somebody's looking at any
candidate yeah let's talk about that for
a sec
because again thinking about what people
talk to me about and message me about
that 100 percent is definitely easily
top three most common topic that people
ask me about again its business
development strategies it's something
that I find challenging what why do you
things become more challenging I think
the obvious answer there's 850
recruitment businesses in the UK SEP
every single month yeah and if you're a
hiring manager the last thing what is
another recruiter you know phoning up
and hammering you and you know I spoke
to one recruitment agency and you know
he's a 1.5 million pound bidder himself
you know you phenomena recruiter and he
says that for every new client he brings
on board he needs to make 50 degrees of
separations it he basically needs to
contact a new client 50 times so that
could be by email what 15 new client
gets has been like 50 50 points of
contact that's mental that could be
obviously differs from my it just shows
you
yeah and he's a 1.5 million pound bill
it's so you know BD is becoming harder
and harder the more saturated the market
is yeah I mean if you think how much
these hiring managers are hammered by
recruiters just me it's been same what
what what are the common things are you
seeing big builders in today's market
knowledge and work ethic really yeah
isn't it is an element of luck yeah
turning you're gonna lead you call that
client they're like we're after a
hundred contract oh wow okay and that
does happen but I think that the biggest
thing is is work ethic and we did around
the office in 37 questions as a know you
know yeah and we asked one of the
questions you know what makes a top
bidder and every single CEO or MD
replied work ethic and you know I know
we try and make recruitment not all
about you know it's working 12 hours day
but how does this fit into flexible work
and me it doesn't you know if you want
to be successful III pay something on
eating if then it got an enormous amount
of traction which is really cool because
I say look if you want to be successful
in anything so I've my best friend is a
seer over like a five six hundred map
man marketing agency he's 39 years old
which is incredible but the guy works
like till midnight every single night
you know I've got a mate who's a
professional rugby player I in orders
kind of bulk up like the guy was just
never out of the gym you know I've got
mates who have very successful lawyers
you know partners in big law firms and
again they've kind of worked 12 13 14
hours a day you know they've had a case
come through they've had to do something
they've had to drop their pants they've
had to work weekends and I think the
same as recruitment like it's so in your
hands that if you want to be successful
you just work harder okay largely no no
no I get that I think I think just just
to add to that I think that was as we
were saying before we started this is
obviously sentence they're the Instagram
life that was well-liked I just couldn't
agree more there obviously it's so easy
just to see the that person at the end
like if you're talking about you mate as
a rugby player or whatever it's so easy
to look at that person the hard core
they got it all right I mean they and
like you just see the minute you don't
see all of the sacrifice and you don't
see all the stuff behind yeah so you
know I mean you you see anyone
you know kind of be successful drive a
nice car wear a nice watch live in nice
house you know and they save inherited
it or married into it or want it or Nick
- it's quite a few ways to earn it but
they've had to worry they've had to
really work hard and you know think you
know I don't think success comes without
a lot of it you know of hard work but
I'd say the other thing as well is
differentiating yourself away from the
competition and that for me is really
understanding your marketing and really
in selling your product so I think there
are recruiters out there who you know
take great pride in great you know
effort to really learn how their market
works so there's a very well-known
recruiter we're all know I would mention
him but he was you know he's just
recently sold a very you know big
recruitment agency for a lot of money
and he was you know start his career at
s3 here's top pillar there and he had a
years you know where he couldn't touch
any of his clients so he decided to be a
trader and he was a trader for a year
and they came back and set up his
business and he built seven hundred
grand from his bedroom in his first year
and it was just because you know a yes
work I think but be really understanding
is you know marker so you know I think
if you want to get to those kind of
levels yeah it's kind of a bit of
combination of both so then like if I'm
listening right now I'm like what what's
like the things that you think about
when it's like right how can I get how
can I really know my market more you
know I mean what the typical thing what
the things that come to mind for you
when you're thinking like that's I mean
what things come to mind so the first
things come to mind I just speak to
people think is anything more powerful
and having conversation with someone and
the other thing is saying I really
struggle with on as young and I watch
kind of the more genius you know staff
in our business it rule they struggle to
ask questions because they're scared to
not know the answer so yeah so I would
go for a meeting and you know client be
wrapping all about this and that and you
acronyms every one bit I don't know what
they're talking about and you know
nowadays I'm not scared not to know and
I say look I don't mean to be ignorant
but what do you mean by that all this
work or you know what you know really
did someone as you got older yeah
definitely I think you should kind of
get a bit more comfort when you
sket yeah I think you're a bit younger
it's kind of case I need to know
everything I need to yes you know
there's no where can kind of MIT you
know you know [ __ ] in my armor so right
so and that that okay I like that and
that's coming that's actually coming up
a couple of times a chap that had them
before for Nicky I promise and I had a
chat before tech recruits and he was
like my biggest realization where things
really start start to happen was like
just don't be afraid to ask stupid
questions and so I think that's great
advice
I was really interested in every CEO
that you've asked have always said work
ethic and I think flexible working and
this sort of stuff is that's that is
that's everywhere and I get and I
totally get that
however there's also got to be a real
conversation around if you if you want
this and these are your ambitions well
guess what like yeah there's gotta be 11
in a sec but do you know what there's
gonna be yeah there has to be
sacrificing you have to work hard but
kind of thinking like why should you
speak in there you could be the
hard-working room but if you don't have
you know the charisma or the ability to
turn it on wins required or close
someone you're not gonna make deals
either yeah so there you gotta be
working right you've got to be doing the
right things we could be working the
right market as well so for example you
know recruiting course lots different
markets you'll be amazed by how much the
top biller from one business saying tags
differs from a top biller in
life sciences you know just the whole
personality the whole really yeah it's
it's very very different
how do you know if the markets for you
then I think you need to almost mirror
your market so if you perhaps are like
if you get along with people you mean
not necessarily oh I think I think what
we doing wreck to wreck you know we're
selling sales people therefore I think
it's important you have you know fairly
banters personality and you can kind of
like you know just just have a very kind
of informal candid low-level
conversation with people because
recruiters and you know sales people
they tend to you know think more with
their heart rather than their head yeah
if you were speaking to someone you know
who works perhaps in private equity
they're pretty gonna come from I know
you know Oxbridge and they can bring you
know incredibly intelligent they're
pretty gonna have much more kind of high
level
hence in-depth conversations so
therefore personality there's no way
that I could work in that market because
I just well as I've told you the
beginning of coat to two distinctly
average University and what what the
what a sort of really exciting markets
at the moment moment that you're saying
technology without doubt is the boom
mark at the moment it has been that way
for a while
how many great is there there are like a
few years many what a few years ago
there was kind of the break off and you
know kind this new market was
established in digital you know think
about your phone like everything use
nowadays is digital so but yeah tech on
it is just driving just driving
everything forwards it so saturated
though it is but it's saturated for a
reason there's still so much no money in
desire and appetite so I think working
right direct you can really get a sense
of what the markets doing because you
can see which companies from which
sector are hiring yeah and technology is
honestly it's just relentless for the
last two three years absolutely
you see never markets shut off a little
bit and not done as well what was that
so banking has really struggled I think
in the last you know couple years yeah I
think you know I think they've had a
pretty hard time with it but at the
market you know G things like you know
brexit like compliance and risk and
corporate governance have probably done
quite well mhm anything to keep an eye
on that you're sort of interested in or
is it literary tech that really comes to
mind when thinking of markers was
anything there yeah there are markets
outside what I do like I say like health
care etc and Sarah hair and those
markets I think are doing well you know
people's you know living
older and this and that like that's kind
of driving that that but um yeah within
the mainstream recruitment laws doing
really well leaves another mark I poke
good I've heard people making some cash
you know what a lot of the biggest
builders I know what candy work really
you know because what they do is they
shift partners but whether shift
partners have UK firms into American
firms that pay them extortion amounts of
money like we're talking massive
seven-figure salaries just to get them
in so you know there's a lot of
seven-figure bill is in the legal market
really but it's but it's like a nautical
blue network you need to work it you
need to kind of like yeah I've heard
that
where's the business demo reliable
environment you've built a real
reputation of yourself worse
I think tech is so much more down to
kind of like yes knowledge and there's
lots of skill except - except it's down
to work at that you can see some people
build big in tech you know two three
years into their into their career which
would never happen legal market what
what what are sort of the things that
you're seeing the the be interesting
again to flip this we're talking about
what people should be looking out for
these types of things but where where do
you think a lot of recruiters that you
speak to sort of fall short and what
what I mean by that is like I was used
to be to recruiters and grads et cetera
all day and your team does what do you
think of the sort of just common like
expectations that people have that it's
just just so far from like what's the
reality and stuff you know I mean what
are the common things that people could
be listening that they you know I mean
what are the common things that people
just the expectations aren't right
they're not they're just so far from
reality if that's in terms of what sort
of interview yeah I just maybe I'm not
being very clear it's like so if I'm a
recruit right now and you're speaking to
me I mean I've been in my four walls and
like my expectation or whether now move
move into another firm and getting a
salary increase over X it's just so far
off the mark you like honestly I know
this market it's not correct but I don't
know I just for we've spoken a lot about
positives and stuff but I foresee again
you you speak to people that listen or
then yeah I think the big I think the
biggest you know what the biggest one is
the moment is people want going to
internal recruitment really yeah it is
obscene I I'm approached
forty times a week by people with the
years or cream experience he wants going
turn or okay and I'm kind of like okay
why and they're like well you know it's
gonna be you know I'm gonna get a nice
big base salary and they're gonna be
nine to five I'm yeah that is
potentially the case but have you ever
thought that you're gonna be a glorified
resource er because as an internal
recruiter all you're gonna do is sort
candidates unless you're at a level of
like ten years experience when actually
you start getting invest in the strategy
and you know this and that but you know
certainly some of you years experiencing
that yeah one of
in internal recruitment 135 40k bass I'm
like you dreaming it's not gonna happen
and the reason you want to do that is
because you can't hack agency life and
agency life is you know a champion
McCrimmon I think it's an awesome crazy
NT but I always say to people getting
into recruitment is but like joining the
gym in January I will be one of those
people who you know is ferociously doing
sit-ups watching what I ate not drinking
and about a second you know we can share
everything all sort this and I will also
be that individual that is walking on
the beach in July thinking oh [ __ ] wish
have a six-pack and I see the guy
opposite me thinking damn and he is the
kind of person that probably got up
every single morning went to the gym
worked hard watch what he ate and
probably think it wasn't that difficult
and recruitments exactly the same if you
you know have a you know understanding
that this is not gonna happen overnight
work really hard for once tears I mean
what are the career can you join other
than recruitment where you can actually
you know outside of you know banking
where you can earn the kind of money you
can do in recruitment and you know
progress is quick you know we have
amazing clients where they've got
directors who've been in the business
five years out of graduating that dad
doesn't happen to any of her industry
and it's kind of a case that work hard
suck it up no it's gonna be bloody hard
but the rewards if you keep going for it
will be good no I'm glad you spoke about
that that's what I was sort of digging
for so I'm glad you got to that point
maybe I wasn't very clear but I think
that's a really interesting point that
more on you've seen a real influx of
people that wanted to go internal and I
think I think that's fair to say that
that's probably a real good reason as to
why people are thinking about that
so just what you're talking about there
is resilience yeah mindset I know you
said at the beginning this like that
obviously your whole sort of life
experience not bring it up bring in and
and helped you probably where you are
now and you said that you have really
good resilience I think what we're
talking about there which again I'm
confident a lot of CEOs would say it's
quite common in in their top millions
and stuff is that resilience peace and
to be willing to brush it off and carry
on how have you I'm sure this is
something you've had to cultivate in the
people in your business and something
that you've continues called
for yourself so I guess what's been your
experience with that that you can share
I think's been really important to hire
people who can display that they have
had to be resilient and that doesn't
necessarily come from Spore or this it's
just you know perhaps they've had a
really tough upbringing and they've had
to just keep fighting or you know this
so many examples means Sport is not
based one but I think I think choosing
the right people to start off with who
haven't been given everything on the
plate so when it doesn't go their own
way I think a lot of people kind of you
know get into the recruitment world and
it doesn't go their own way and they've
got a fullback option I think people who
kind of like I haven't got anything else
to so I need to make this work they're
the kind of individuals do really well
but resilience without doubt I mean I
used to run a lot of assessment dates
for businesses around the city and we
used to talk about you know what makes a
good recruiter and you know people used
to shout out you know competitive
confident motivated resilient ambitious
and when you kind of break them all down
you know very few were skill set they
were all attitudes with resilience
probably been the number one and it it
is it is so important especially those
first beat like even as like some
evening dinner job 16 years like there
are days what I want to you know kind of
just curl in a ball and cry because
nothing's gone your way yeah and that
never goes away have you got better at
dealing with out there GRU personally
because I'm sure some people can learn
from that in my day to day job it's I
suppose being a creature it's making
sure we've got pipeline so that if you
have one thing fall out you've got
enough positive things focus on so never
always have just be relying on one thing
no because I think if you're always you
know even relying everything on that
it's very detrimental like you know all
your focus goes into that negativity
worries actually we've got you know two
more good cameras you can think are you
know bugger it didn't go my way but
you're focusing on those two people and
I think that really really helps but you
know if resilience comes in many forms I
suppose and you could you know look at
the people I've hired over the years and
they would have all have so many
different stories about why they're
resilient really yeah okay and you know
what it's a really difficult thing to
kind of like judge interview I know we
all kind of like try and ask for
examples and
it is and you don't really get to
understand some whose true colors until
they've perhaps been doing the job a
while I mean for example we've got the
gun guy in our office and he has just
been so unlucky like everything's gone
against it like he's had fine after fine
after fine I'll go ahead and he's been
with us pre about two months and the guy
comes in every day smiling the guy you
know gets in first he leaves last and
you just think you know what he will get
it because here he will do it's too easy
to give up I think that's a really
important thing to note that though
isn't it like what you're talking about
there is that it's the activities and
the things that he's doing on a daily
basis that gives you the confidence you
know I actually hit the post a lot of
times but he is gonna he's gonna get it
and it's gonna click and it is going to
happen for him yeah definitely that's a
really important thing that if it isn't
happening for you well make sure that at
least you're not you are still doing the
right activities and giving yourself
every opportunity you can to get it
right do you know I mean nothing Isis
it's such an important like that's what
I got a lot of because I openly say I
build [ __ ] on my first year 24k makes
[Laughter]
the business and he said to me he
shouldn't keep them we're doing you've
hit the post a lot but like it's gonna
pay off
I just know it it's just keep doing
we're doing and I just think that's such
an important thing to make sure that you
are doing if you're having a struggling
month you are having a bit of a [ __ ]
year but what the one thing that really
strikes me is how people talk about
recruitment being like it's really hard
like recruitment is not hard like being
successful hard and again I made a post
about this every day and you can look at
sportsmen like let's take a batsman and
cricket like they could be absolute on
fire and some they go through a summer
of just absolute turmoil yeah and you
know their confidence drops an all-time
low but you know Andy Murray's two sets
down yeah you you need to have that kind
of it doesn't matter what job you do
recruitment isn't tough you know any job
to be successful you have to work hard
you have to kind of you know counter you
know not back you have to work hard it's
the differences in recruitment
you can come from not doing it in like
what having done ever and in two years
be you know prolific in the job perhaps
not prolific but you know I know I mean
it's only you know very capable
and I'm in and what's been some of the
bigger learners that you've experienced
having your own business mate
what how have you found that um yeah yes
do you know what running your own
business is you know it's amazing
there's loads of highs there's loads of
lows so much keep like a really level
head I think that's a good thing yeah I
could probably give you a million highs
pretty good and it depends you know what
happens in a day like we've just had a
really good month and we've had a riga
day in evans in Riga mood and so I'm
kind of feeling very positive about
things you know II could go into the
office on Monday we've had X amount
dropouts or you know all our clients you
know shut up hiring and I might have a
very different yeah I mean I look at it
and I think that's very typical of
recruiters is you know when they're in
the job they don't like they're really
grumping they hate their life Monday
Tuesday Wednesday Thursday
[ __ ] it's Thursday Thursday live
brilliant can't get pierced Friday bacon
rolls and it's the weekend and I think a
lot of recruiters kind of forget you
know even though they're in happy in the
role they kind of don't do anything
about it and it kind of comes back back
to that like it's if but if you were
speaking someone that there was listen
to this podcast and their finger about
starting or an agency what sort of comes
to mind in terms of some of the things
that you be speaking about or or or make
sure that you've got across that they
knew or thought about before they start
their own agency look without being too
boring cash plays King yeah it really is
so the amount of recruiting businesses I
see who you know spend a fortune on
entertainment you know taking their
staff on amazing holidays amazing
offices but yet they've gotten their
money in the bank it doesn't make any
sense for her so you know there'll be a
situation for example if we had a
downturn in the market you will see a
lot of companies go bust because they
kind of live hand-to-mouth and it's
month-to-month
so cash flow is always king in any
business aside from that just having a
really clear vision and this isn't me
kind of speaking from my own experience
it's more kind of you know meeting so
many recruitment owners or businesses
looking at the successful ones and
seeing what they do they have a very
clear vision of what they want
and it's kind of right this year we need
to you know hi this many people this is
the market we need to move it they know
exactly what they're gonna do
has that typically come from the
beginning you found what's that has that
typically come for the people you were
talking about is that typically come
from Germany because that can be quite
difficult to start Connor yeah there are
loads of businesses started off as live
start businesses yeah cup of people in
the room done really well you know kind
of found their way just just enjoyed
life and they've kind thought actually
want to establish something and you know
they've been built saying a lot more
kind of not credible but just
professional and slick and you know more
structured alright well huh what is on
this sort company topic and stuff what's
like the worst company bug that you've
seen the worst can free perk I'll show
you seen some bad ones ah you got a
selling mate that's really for that
recruit you wouldn't believe this but
I'm only he's the second the best things
about that's like yeah you want to join
this business but this perks are really
[ __ ] but just some of the things you've
got no way is that like a selling point
you know I mean free fruit really does
my nut in I'm like we have free fruit in
the office and wise up her and but why
is that a perk okay another one is right
recycle to work so basically the company
would buy oh boy that's something that
the government says and you don't have
any option about it it's a it's like
yeah but the free fruit kind of gets me
it's I know if you need to you know
persuades them to join you by buying the
15 P apples yeah what just on this note
again kids get your force I think what
what do you think recruitment businesses
need to as you said you place we have
over a hundred recruitment businesses
what do you think that people listening
maybe they're recruiting for their team
or whatever like what what do you think
people can do way better to to make them
stands you know man everyone says
they're different
everyone says they're unique but yeah
yeah yeah so that was 116 last year like
in terms of my career I've replaced well
over like 400 businesses yeah but in
terms of
salespeople are very simple individuals
I think and I don't mean any offense by
that but what I mean by that is we buy
of people we like and you can go for an
interview of someone and they can give a
very professional detail about what the
businesses can give you like a really
amazing visionary but if it's very
static and it doesn't kind of they don't
engage with you unlike a social level
you're never gonna kind of win I don't
think I think the best business is who
attracts you know staff really well they
treat them as people so they kind of
build really amazing relationships with
them they you know show them they're
very honest yeah actually can has
responded really well to honesty
nowadays it's like look this is what we
really struggle with or this is a can
that we've had he's worked for six
months they really struggle they didn't
make a deal for the first five months
but this is how we develop them this is
how we brought them out the other side
and kind of giving honest case that is a
really big thing but the biggest thing
is a can that be able to visualize what
it's like to work for that business
before they even started yeah you know
it's amazing how many of my clients for
example won't show a can that around the
office which I think's bizarre a cement
or if gonna work what 10 11 hours a day
mental it's like first day see I'll just
kids get I think that's some really good
points I think what I've seen in the
sort of world that I'm in now is what
what I've seen I did a post biosilver
they like what I've seen being like it's
so simple but it's been not really
effective is like if you're recruiting
for your recruitment business and you're
selling you're allowing like you just
said there visualize what it like to be
worked there and you can very easily
allow me to have a bit of a window into
rule recruitment you know I mean if
that's you showcasing the people in your
business celebrating their successes
being honest with some of the milestones
that you've hit or some of the ones that
you struggle to hit for me what I've
seen that's gone down actually really
well for me what I don't know if you
agree this but for me there's so many
sort of business leaders and recruiting
agencies that actually there could be
absolutely brilliant but actually don't
have a face at all online yeah they just
look the same yeah and that it's
actually being crazy that I could be a
recruitment business owner right now and
I could actually start taking pictures
of when I bring out a birthday cake for
someone's happy birthday or to take a
picture of people when they've hit a
certain milestone wave and that could
actually then enable me to engage some
experienced hires and actually mental
case only case that
the most powerful way of selling no
doubt about it because yeah I mean you
can talk about about this and about that
and you know into a candidate they know
this opposite a slick salesperson so you
know that is always going to be
fabricating the exaggerated to a degree
but giving real-life examples I often
think those examples coming from the
individual themselves look it's a it's a
more powerful thing yeah definitely but
it's amazing how people many people
don't kind of showcase you know they're
offering but it's equally amazing how
many people do showcase their offering
kind of and yet that's when they're all
about it I call it this kind of
Instagram area of recruitment where
everyone's you know I'm not sure about
you but everyone I follow on Instagram
it's like I'm gonna beat young skiing
it's like honestly there's not never
like [ __ ] my kids up at like 3 o'clock
in the morning and yeah or you know my
milk scooter you tell you right to pick
up an axe and then it's like that
honestly that really resonates for
people cuz that's what that's the
reality of people's lives rather than
just always being an on beefer because
we hit our big bill of targets you know
the problem is that every similar
Crippen business have those kind of
incentives nowadays mhm so this is one
of the difficult things for me as a
wreck to wreck it's actually approaching
people and saying look you're in this
business I know what this business is to
work for trust me I really understand
this market there's not million years
I'd ever work for your business there
are a plethora of like businesses out
there that are so much I don't know just
they've got everything your business
hasn't like from support from nice
culture they don't bash you with kpi's
they make you work 12 hours they they
actually pay you and reward you they
want to pay out big paychecks here and
it's kind of but because there's so much
publicity online there's a real I think
it's a real difficulty of getting people
to understand that there is that and the
grass can be clean greener over yeah you
talking bollocks you just trying to sell
me a roll yeah on this just before we
finish I think again I'm just thinking
of like what people how you can give a
lot of value to people listening
commisioner structures what's a good
commission structure me it's funny
because every single can't i go to
they're always like i say i think it
depends how you set your agency up you
know some agencies will really
incentivize
you know Top Billing so for example I've
got a client who will pay you 50% but
anything you below but 500 grand really
they've got about three four hundred
three for 500k billa's so they're
bailing like 253 in the ground the end
oh they'll pay you 50% if you hit by
100k on everything which is exceptional
there are other recruitment businesses
out there that will incentivize the
masses but if you're a really big billet
you're not going to get you know massive
visa look the at the rule is in Croton
business is you should run a third a
business sure third and a third go an
operation cost okay so third a third is
what you should own a t-shirt if you
include your base yeah so look at your
berlin's and lightwire should be earning
about a phone that's a good sort
Benjamin yeah if you're not only thirty
bit Billings and you're in the wrong
business there's no doubt about it yeah
almost basic salary it I feel like this
has gone up in recruitment what's the
craic with that well the market is that
we've mentioned before is so saturated
companies are kind of thinking you know
how to attract people and base salaries
obviously one of the easiest ways I mean
base salaries and recruitment have not
gone up a huge amount videos I mean when
I first item recruitment I think I was
paying about 16 K base but I was like 16
years ago I started 17 K babe if my rent
was 400 pounds a month I lived in a
really nice Mews house and ones with
common but I reckon if you pay for in a
pounds a month now you'd be the garage
in yeah yes yeah so like what what again
I think again you're in the Union
positions you know I mean people may not
know they're yeah decent base so the top
end the kind of graduate market is
paying around about 25 kr to the
averages run about 20 to 23 some of the
years experienced 28 30 but this is
where recruitment can sorta here's
experience 20 at fair but this is what
it's about to say so there's so many
different permutations because you could
have someone with two years experience
in recruitment who builds 300 grand the
year you could please we have some over
two years experience in recruitment in
who bills
80 around the year so it's so down to
its to the level that you you know and
also you know how much business they
bring in yeah yeah salary it sorry
your basic Terry's got you know
dramatically really okay I think I think
I just think again because recruitment
again go back to what we talked about
and talking about recruitment becoming
career yes true it's not so much you
know when I started was all about low
load base salaries hike you know
Commission opportunities it's their
agency style yeah and nowadays like that
doesn't wash people actually recruitment
is starting to compete against you know
professional services you know jobs and
you know the job so I think people are
seeing it more as creating therefore
they want the base salary that comes
with that a little bit okay before
before I she said you're excited about
stuff and we finished what 2020 and
beyond what what you think and mate how
does next year that like recruitment was
do you know what the there's so many
clients saying they're looking next year
already and they've got a really big
kind of aggressive a kind of expansion
plans and that's really exciting like
really exciting you know the overall
recruitment market in the UK looks like
it's going to expand you know I asked my
clients about breaks in you know all the
time and so many companies have kind of
you know tried to mitigate themselves
from those kind of downturns in the
market by you know working Europe or
work in this you know in America are
working you know high-level roles are
gonna be necessary you know they're
gonna still be out there but yeah I
think 2020 2020 looks good it's not
there's not many people who are saying
yeah it looks like it's about that's all
part so before I actually the final
question what we excited about me what's
going on in your world that you and a
shout about what's going on okay a very
difficult question my life is
recruitment si excited about you all see
you've got so anyone that has it's it's
47 isn't that sorry it's their video so
if anyone hasn't seen around the office
in 37 questions I've fought their
brilliant thank you um but yeah well
like what I don't know is anything you
want a shout about what you excited
about it's going on in your world look I
think we got some exciting plans that
rule next year we're kind of trying to
train the guys to work a much more
senior level market because the demand
in you know recruitment for senior
professionals it's got to be the most
buoyant recruiting market there is and I
think there are a lot of people work on
industry but there aren't a lot of
people who could perhaps you know are up
to the level where they've got can add
as much value
minh you know other things
I mean plugged into last question then
yeah cuz if you could communicate to
every single rocker out there they take
on an advice they listen they implement
it could be a phrase a word
what would you say mate I'm sorry I
can't do this in Word - brace yourself
everyone I suppose is you know listen to
your own advice I think recruiters are
really scared about being caught or
scared that isn't something out there I
think if you've got a notion that you're
not working for the right equipment
business
it doesn't mean recruitments not for you
and weeks being so many recruiters who
say yeah I've done recruitment I just
[ __ ] hate it
excuse my language and and I'm like just
because if I went for an Indian and I
had a really bad Indian it wouldn't be
something wooden put me off India first
in my life and I think being open enough
to kind of think you know what I'm gonna
have a look at another four or five
agencies and see what was out there and
if you come away and think you know what
it's not for me then walk away but you
know I think sometimes knowing what you
don't want in life helps you know what
you do want yeah any of you that
actually think you don't
Wow like I can't believe how different
that recruitment agency is to my
recruiting agency because that's the
biggest thing I get speaking to people
like two-threes experience they can't
actually believe how different it is to
their own kind of experience so I kind
of say look if you've got any doubts go
and have a look at the market you don't
have to commit to anything but just
knowing what you don't want my help you
know what you want I think that's great
advice mate it's been a pleasure thank
you James
cheers buddy